you know a lot of people are worried
about flying these days
and it's turning out that actually a lot
of the airlines are being very good it
can be quite safe
to uh to fly uh because of all the
precautions they're taking
uh with keeping people separated and
being extra careful
but i know that you have a fear of
flying even when there is no coronavirus
you've always been afraid to fly is that
right
yes i'm terrified of flying which is a
big handicap given that i fly
uh all the time for my job i mean
many times a year and um no it's
dreadful i i don't know what to do about
it and it's got me in
terrible sort of pickles in the past
because i
end up getting very confessional on
airplanes thinking that
i'm definitely plummeting to my doom and
i need to kind of
offload myself of all my deepest darkest
secrets and uh
and then i don't die and um and i've
told some perfect stranger
everything about myself and i did it
once
on a flight to yalta i was doing um i
was doing a job in
in yalta in the ex-soviet union
and um and uh i was sitting next to a
very nice man
and i you know those flights are
terrifying they're they're
they're it was an aeroflot internal
flight which you're told that sort of um
you know people that work for embassies
and things are banned from going on
because i think on average about 20
people a week die on them because
they're mainly driven by
very drunk ex equivalent of raf russian
um pilots who get bored and sort of do
loot the loops drunk
and then crash and um and they were
literally
laughing but if a drug pilot decides to
do a loop-de-loop
it's hard not to giggle a little bit
exactly
apart from when you're on the plane um
anyway and so i got on this plane and
they were literally sort of
newspapers stuffing up the windows and
kind of there was like three the safety
precautions were three
um parachutes that were sort of dotted
around various places in the airplane
and i just knew i was gonna die so i
i offloaded all my really sort of
were secrets to this very nice gentleman
who was sitting next to me
and then realized that he was in fact in
the show that i was about to go and film
this very sweet man knowing everything
about me and and
winking knowingly whenever i sort of
walked into the bar and i think oh my
god
you knew everything yeah your secret's
safe with me
well guess what i contacted that man and
he told me anything
and i want to ask you about it now
wouldn't that be a fun turn of events
yes it would be amazing
you studied acting in russia didn't you
i did i did well i didn't really i
studied russian at university in england
and then i did a year abroad
um as a sort of uh practice year but i
didn't learn anything because i went to
drama school
in in moscow and uh i just got a huge
crush on the guy that was teaching me
russia and drama oh oh
that's classic that's classic for people
to get a crush on their instructor
you know especially when you're young
and you're in a foreign country
what was this guy like was he very
commanding you know
sort of impressive guy he was called
dmitry bruznikian
and um he was well in my mind's eye
he was all of those things um but i i
don't know i think love is blind maybe i
don't know
i'm sure he was all of those things but
i uh i
just was obsessed by him and i didn't
get pick up any knowledge either of
acting or i've had to speak russian but
um i did finally get him back
to my apartment for dinner with uh
you know i i staged this whole thing
where there were the other students that
had been on my course and
i made this delicious dinner for
everybody and he did lo and behold
walk out onto the balcony um
and start sort of looking up at the moon
and talking about the moon and
and quite seemingly quite sort of
romantic terms
but i unfortunately was so drunk on um
vodka because i was so excited that i
had him in my house that um
i started vomiting silently behind him
and i knew i was going to be sick but i
didn't want to leave
so i would sort of sit quietly into my
hands behind him
he didn't notice he was so engrossed in
his
in his he was waxing so lyrical at the
moon that he didn't
have failed to notice me vomiting behind
him and i can't really remember how it
played out but it's sort of i think i
went off him
that he didn't notice that he was so
self-involved he didn't notice
behind him uh that's the least romantic
story i've ever heard
you uh i you're wow okay
i like that you discreetly threw up
which is a very hard thing to do
in a very ladylike fashion i did i did